hello welcome to this video PT caprius
their opponent I have not pin started
the video on time but it didn't lose
much time ok that's good um there it
goes for the Catalan that's not very
exciting yeah that's um under a skid
Lyris it's the sinus no number one
player of Cyprus I have a pretty good
scoop against him not quite sure why
this is so great plus 6 even though he
constantly has similar ratings to mine
ok this is currently one of the main
continuation seeing them and the Catalan
let's see i'm really not an expert IAM
not sure with this a 5 quite often you
play this and then put a night on before
which is now not possible the King so
maybe get the bishop pair and
potentially after you have to take this
year before he goes with eform this kind
of position is usually quite ok for
black pin it's super solid you cannot do
much but this is what it is sometimes in
the Catalan age for I see going forward
for g for business here I cannot believe
that maybe but it's so hard to believe
ok so here I can ask him about the
screen
95 you will probably move the night to
swoop the eight yeah this should be
quite okay for me this position hard to
believe that white should have anything
here your plants maybe I can play you
five in the long run and also wonder if
i can if i take on c4 and someone will
get denied over to be six i might be
able to do something against the points
but ok it doesn't look does it look very
lightly
mhm 5mm stuff to attack this take the
point it's kind of on its own but you
cannot cut out a ticket okay I'm going
back here maybe playing Bishop b4 next
okay he's maybe trying for Bishop back
and then lining up for this battery yet
the idea was just that he cannot put the
bishop behind the queen of this was the
idea and and now here if five maybe if I
huh let's open up the position we should
f5 if he can do though I didn't see that
it's a bit unfortunate actually okay you
look give five take that mmhmm yeah not
ideal it's probably still not a big deal
but it wasn't what I intended yeah I can
take if I've theoretically speaking but
it looks strange
look son coordinated let's aim
if i take take a couple of times they I
don't get it back unfortunately mmm
yeah something like that and he's trying
to play is six ok so maybe here you have
a pawn down but its opposite colored
bishop so there are always join to see
2-2 draw let's see I book doesn't have
many squares this is definitely
definitely true and is some is six maybe
at some point g-form still not possible
I am down to a minute this is this is
actually what concerns me most the
position is not great but maybe okay
time morning you might be able to get
the bishop over to see eight which is
quite a problem
he was close to cutting my work off jack
okay justice this is something that i
cannot i cannot them decline them to the
trade i have to h5 let's get rid of
pawns there ok take this this so how to
do it i have to go to see one here maybe
I should have done that earlier Scott E
5v5 common check
I will lose on time anyway the position
might be lost as well is it is lost
unfortunately I don't think that this
was strictly necessary really but CMC is
skeptical about Jan we can advance check
check check yes 165 it's the right it's
right corner yeah ultimately I'm my
problem was said i blundered this pawn
and it just was just a one move blunder
in a position you can never possibly
lose yeah this position is just dead
equal if anybody maybe black ass venom
c5 here I just I just didn't see Bishop
f5 I mean i blundered this basically and
now the position is somewhat annoying
after he takes and maybe I should take
this pawn I felt like I'm badly
coordinated which is definitely true
here but maybe this is not really a
problem this is what the engine is
giving and I didn't see that i have
rupee 7 hear that
covering this and have Ruby seven yeah
this is not much yeah this way I'm not
sure still have pretty good drawing
chances but it is not not fun at all
check check Kim and here where you get
seasick sin it's probably lost the four
points is probably lost in very likely
lost yeah yeah not much to say actually
it was a pretty normal kind of nothing
happens game and here I shouldn't go
with five or if I do I should not play
with the pawn down just see five and
nothing happens here the engine gives me
an advantage with this you cannot win
this position probably ever I mean I
have some pressure here but its opposite
colored bishops if you win a pawn on d4
you still withdraw so now that's a bit
stupid really yeah yeah maybe I should
have been after playing a five I
probably should have taken here for to
take in here moment I detected take a
moment to just determine if I can take
this but I still felt I should have good
drawing chances because of the optical
political officials well it's not it's
not that bright not that great okay well
thanks for watching